this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Monday February the
5th the joint is brought to you by
rocket money how much are you paying for
all your subscriptions you don't even
know you could be wasting hundreds of
dollars each month on subscriptions you
don't even know about well you forgot
about that's why I love rocket money
formerly known as true bill listen I've
already gotten things from people that
have already download the app and they
love it because the app will show you
all your subscriptions in one place
cancels whatever ones you don't want and
remind you the ones you have rocket
money can even find you ones you didn't
even know you were paying for you may
even find out you've been double charged
to cancel a subscription just press
cancel and Rocket money takes care of
the rest it's that easy so get rid of
useless subscriptions save money with
rocket money now go to rocketmoney.com
Joey seriously if I could save you a
couple hundred dollars a year you will
love your uncle even more so do me a
favor
rocketmoney.com Joey cancel your
unnecessary subscriptions save some
money and let rocketmoney.com
slash Joey do the rest again
rocketmoney.com Joey you're gonna love
me for this the joint is also brought to
you by oh my goodness DraftKings listen
two title fights one Epic night I'm
talking about UFC 284 and that's just
sadly you got Michael Shaw fighting
all right and then we're gonna roll
right into Sunday with the [__] Super
Bowl join the MMA action with DraftKings
Sportsbook and official sports betting
part of the UFC new customers listen
five dollars and you're gonna get 200
and bonus bets just like that listen I
love this card there's a lot of great
fights on this card a lot of fighter
props fighter props on this card so take
a look and don't forget that the big
game is Sunday the following day so it's
going to be a great weekend but it
starts with you download the app now use
code Joey and new customers bet five
dollars on UFC 284 and get 200 and bonus
bets instantly this Saturday DraftKings
sports book with code Joey minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details let's get this
party started
Monday morning I got [__] to do
[Music]
it
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
what's happening you bad [__]
Uncle Joey here for another fun-filled
Monday morning motivation [__]
podcast that's a lot of words just to
get started in this [__]
everything's beautiful it's February 5th
[__] uh the penguins have finally
showed up in New Jersey you know I love
I I just love people how [__] dumb we
are you know a fighter wins a fight and
he's back you know I remember it was
there was two games during football
season there were two games that just
passed and Dallas had won that Sunday
and I was at the gym Monday and they're
already like this is the Dallas Cowboys
or uh Super Bowl Contender why are we
talking about this because they won one
game we are so impressed with the
dumbest [__] as Americans listen I grew
up on the east coast and I know one
thing for sure
we're going to get 100 inches of snow
when that's going to come nobody knows
but it's coming do you know what I'm
saying like I already saw people it was
like 62 days last week and people like
oh [__] Indian this the Stars relax
cocksucka February is coming and what
happened on [__] Thursday it dropped
to five I went to Pennsylvania it was
five degrees and 10 with the [__]
wind chill okay where's everybody with
that bikini now with the Indian summers
here we were [__] [__] now it's
gonna warm up again and they're already
jumping up and down again oh by
Wednesday it's going to be 60. [__]
February 19th is around the corner and
let me tell you something I know for a
fact I don't know much about global
warming I don't know what the [__]
going on with the climate I don't know
about Greta thumbberg I have no [__]
idea of the balloons from China you know
what the [__] all I do know is that
every year when I was growing up there
was always snow on the ground February
19th except two years ago there wasn't
snow here but times are changing but
it's still gonna [__] be colder than
a [__] so before you bust out
you a little bit can look at Texas
Texas was freezing last [__] week
they had to cancel one of the basketball
games because the the [__] team
couldn't get out of that when a team
can't get out of a city what does that
[__] tell you shit's [__] gone
wild on that [__] but that's it
it's February I'm excited I'm done with
the uh
residency till [__] God knows when
we're just working on the book now and
hopefully uh that'll make a splash when
it comes on April 23rd but I want to
talk about this week you know every week
you get thrown
so much [__] news you know like every
week you start on Monday the [__] that
you don't expect Governor Santos this
that and it's [__] that when you think
about it it doesn't matter to you at all
that's why I kind of gave up I'm not
good with current offense because Karen
Affairs because it just doesn't matter
no more every week is more and more
[__] and if you go into it you know
Tim Allen's showing his dick [__] now
I gotta listen to [__] Baywatch all
week I don't want to you know so you
just avoid all that [__] I didn't see
the documentary I tried to put it on for
three minutes and I I can't watch this
[__] and I like playing with Pamela
Anderson I think we've all whacked off
to a one point Our Lives I remember I
was in County Jail in Seattle banging
them out to a picture of Pamela Anderson
but what the [__] we're just being
honest on a Monday morning
but the news that struck me weird this
week and only one other person called me
with it and said this is [__] up
was Ozzy Osbourne
I don't know if you guys realize
what that meant with Ozzy Osbourne
saying I can't do it no more it's the
beginning of the end
it's the beginning of the end
you know and guys you know I love Ozzy
Osbourne Over the years you
you grow up and you [__] get into
this and you get into this and this and
this but like you lose a lot of [__]
that you ever put on now Mom when you
were a kid and you really wanted to work
feel like this just doesn't work in my
life anymore I don't know I could yeah
we just grow up out of some music some
music stays with you forever some music
I get pissed off that I still listen to
like Joey what the [__] grow the [__] up
you know listen to something different
and I try you know but you I'll taste
change my taste have never changed with
Ozzy Osbourne like when I'm driving and
I hear an old Ozzy song or a Black
Sabbath song it's just like listen Crazy
Train you know whatever but there's some
other jams in there in between Ozzie's
Boneyard plays that it stops me
sometimes you know because 20 years ago
when I was growing up they wouldn't play
[__] Black Sabbath on the radio at
all at all not even War Pigs then
Aussies what do you think Ozzy started
that [__] station nobody played his
goddamn music grew up you would never
hear any [__] Black Sabbath on the
radio but it's funny how
you know guys I saw this comedy boom
grow and I saw the reaction that
people young adults you know adults of
all ages responded
to the podcast which created a different
type
of admiration from people now it made it
simpler for you to like them or not like
them when I was growing up and I'd watch
uh
I don't know
some [__] comedian uh Freddie Prince
I knew he was Puerto Rican I knew he was
from the Bronx but I didn't know he
played with guns I didn't know he did
blow I didn't know he was going through
all that if he had a podcast
we would have known and things would
have been different Richard Pryor you
know because what the podcast opened up
was
how we feel about things opinions we
open up some podcasters open up their
family
when I first started doing a podcast I I
got to tell you this uh I don't know
like maybe two years into the Church
podcast
a kid moved from like I don't know some
other State to California he wanted to
hook up with me and I was like dog what
do you want to talk about he wanna he
was aspiring to be a comedian I go
listen I'm at the story now
store he's like no no no no I want to
see you in North Hollywood in the
daytime
I'm I'm [__] busy I got the kid I got
the podcast
I'm doing stupid [__] I'm going to
[__] meetings to sell a show you know
when I lived there my schedule was all
over the [__] place so
I said just go to the [__] store
no I would go to a weed store and they'd
say some guy was here for an hour
waiting for you and I'd go to a [__]
oh my god there was places I could just
go and he would just leave
dude some guy was here waiting for you
he thinks you come over here Mexicano
all the time this happened at like three
or four places meanwhile I'm
corresponding with the guy the guy is
basically living a mile from me in North
Hollywood I'm corresponding with him and
every [__] day he's like and then one
day he just went off on me I don't want
to go to a [__] store you know I
don't like audiences okay then what are
we talking about here he went off on me
you know
you know and then he wrote me like a
touching note he goes you don't
understand I don't want nothing from you
you know this is the beginning of the
podcast boom guys and all of a sudden
people are knocking on your door and
people sending you emails that you know
we didn't know what you know we came
from a [__] stand-up comedy with
nobody talked to you
I did a million shows and not one person
ever came up to me and said hey great
show or you know you're gonna be a star
or nothing nobody ever talked to me now
everybody wanted to talk to you so
you're like what the [__] is going on so
I didn't know how to react to this kid
I'll never forget
that he wrote me this [__] note this
is embarrassing but I'll tell you guys
and because this is how I related at the
time
he goes you know I just really wanted to
meet you and stuff and I thought about
his story and I go listen bro
if you would have said that in the
beginning I thought you wanted to talk
about stand-up comedy I I didn't know
what the [__] you want to talk about
and he's like you know
he just wrote a bunch of flattering
stuff
you know I was like what the [__] is
this what a podcast does
and I finally said I wrote him a note
and I go listen we can hook up tomorrow
at such and such time I didn't know that
I go I get what you're saying to me I go
you lost a parent he was in the same
position as me he lost a parent and I
spoke about losing a parent and he
connected and I go you know
it's sort of like when I was a kid how I
connected with Ozzy Osbourne for some
reason I don't know I connected with
Ozzy when I saw him on stage and then I
went home and listened to him we'll get
to that story but I get it I get it and
he wrote back you ain't no Ozzy Osbourne
like I didn't paraphrase it like how is
Ozzy I go now I understand where you're
coming from you're relating to me
because of the death or something like
that and that's you know I was a kid I
was into the doors I was into
Ted Nugent and it took me a long time to
get into that music because they had
long hair and I was scared of people
with long hair at the time I was a young
Cuban Catholic and you know and if I did
like them I would [__] not say
nothing to anybody
and then Zeppelin came into my life when
I was like you know I'm out there
playing basketball at 10 and I'm hearing
black dog
when you hit black dog when you're 10
years old in the summer when you're
drinking an orange drink you're like
what the [__] I even put on black dog
today and you're like what is this but
hold on let me power forward let me
[__] uh get one of those goggles and
transport yourself to 1973 when this
song came out you had never heard
anything like that
I mean you know you knew he was trying
to get his dick sucked in the song you
know he just knew as a 10 year old
you're like it excited you
I Love Led Zeppelin but I never got you
know I I don't know I don't know what
happened all I know is I had
Zeppelin too I had a couple Yes albums
you know I liked fragile
I'm like yes over the edge
had the doors
I had to sewing man's the same I had Led
Zeppelin too Led Zeppelin
three and I had presence you know I was
just getting my [__] going you know what
I'm saying I had double live Gonzo I had
Cat Scratch Fever I had Hotel California
these were you know 1975 this is what
you had in your house I like the eagles
I [__] love the Eagles I liked uh
one of these nights I think it's a
tremendous jam and then that album was
followed by Hotel California so I kind
of like the eagles
and one day I'm at the [__] uh courts
or whatever and I hear you know the
beginning to wallpaper
you know and I tell you when you hear
War Pigs for the first time when once
they get into the guitar
you want to lose your [__] mind like
you run to the record store
you know what I'm saying I don't know
there's something about war base you
know there's something about [__] War
Pigs and then you bring the album home
and it's electric funeral that's a
little [__] scary some guy Electric
Funeral you're like what the [__] you
know yeah you know Electric Funeral what
am I getting electrocuted tonight you
got [__] uh
uh my favorite song of the ham is what
you gonna do times caught up with you
it's that's as real as it gets at that
age I like the stones I'd get your
Yaya's out I'd miss you no I didn't I I
think I had it it's only rock and roll
at that time Michigan didn't come out
till 78 or something like that
and I I don't know maybe in the eighth
grade I heard Black Sabbath on the
courts and I was like this is pretty
[__] good but I'm a Catholic you know
what I'm saying he's over there talking
about Satan spreading his wings
it's okay till Satan spread his
[__] wings okay then it was all
over and then I started smoking pot and
blah blah blah blah
and I don't know
I heard it again
and I borrowed it from somebody I think
maybe Steve avillo one of my friend The
Villa from the Past Masters I borrowed
it and when I heard paranoid
after [__] War Pigs and I heard all
that music
I was like this is [__] pretty good
but I'm still into the Eagles I'm still
into Zeppelin I'm going to keep these
[__] in the back burner you
know what I'm saying
this is still a little out there for me
and then
I get the freshman year and yeah I don't
know they're bullshitting about
something on the bus they're gonna go
see Black Sabbath
and I go yeah I kind of like them you
know I mean you know at that age I
didn't know their whole [__]
I liked War Pigs and I like paranoid and
I said [__] it and uh me and some people
from downtown till this day I know who I
saw there at the concert the garden was
filled with [__] North Bergen people
and I but I'm still to this day I forget
who the [__] I walked into that place
with the rumor was you had to get there
early because the warm-up band was going
to be tremendous the warm-up band was
Van Halen
and [__] you know I walked in there
guys I didn't know [__] I had been to
one concert before that it was maybe Ted
Nugent with Aerosmith at The Meadowlands
outside it was like one of those all-day
concerts [__] Aerosmith busted their
guitars though it was not you know we
walked home
when I walked in there
first of all the electricity from Van
Halen and I didn't know why the Van
Halen was I could sit here and tell you
I was ready I knew eruption I didn't
know dick
so think about how I felt when I saw
[__] eruption up there we maybe
smoked a few joints I don't know if I
did acid or anything at that point I was
still a little half a [__] I still had to
put Visine in my eyes when I went home
and cologne and I don't know what I did
but I remember that Black Sabbath came
on and I didn't know what sounded good
and what didn't sound good I just knew
that some of their instruments were off
like I could hear like guitars strings
popping and you know it just wasn't and
I could see the drummer snorting coke
Bill Ward was snorting coke from the
snare drum right on that not that snare
drum but and I was like wow this is
[__] great so we left that show and
the next day I went to North Bergen and
on the way home I would walk on
Bergenline and pick up the album of the
week and I picked up [__] paranoid
and lights out guys lights out what he
was talking about I [__] liked I
didn't know what he was talking about I
know at the one Jam I like it's about
heroin and uh you know I didn't know
anything else about them at the time it
was maybe
October of 78 I think they did October
18th or something like that check it out
I don't know
and then I bought the second album I
bought
because I want I said [__] it I like
this band I'm not going to do what I did
with the rest of my
uh album career I'm gonna start from
scratch
you know because like with the stones I
started with like it's only rock and
roll get your Yaya's out the way to do
it is from the [__] beginning and
then you just I didn't like the early
Stones I didn't catch on until I mean I
like it you know 19 nervous breakdown
all that [__] but
you know what I mean I like that to
[__] like uh goat's head soup and all
that when they got down and dirty
when I put when I put that Black Sabbath
out
when I heard the first song Black
Sabbath Black Sabbath I turned that
[__] off
I turned that [__] off I was
like this ain't phone call Joey what is
this that stands before me figure in
Black pointing at me this is not gonna
work in my world and I think I moved on
to the wizard because the wizard was
kind of a popular song and everybody in
your neighborhood wanted to be a [__]
wizard you know so the wizard was it and
I guess that was my I like the album and
then I said [__] it let me put on
Black Sabbath Black Sabbath and then I
just I was like okay and that was by the
summer I had rented a house down the
shore with two of my buddies and two
girl three girls from high school we
weren't dating them they were next door
to us and we rented this house and I
bought that [__] Black Sabbath Black
Sabbath on eight track
and I still remember the [__] player
I had it's the first eight-track player
I had that I put Pink Floyd Dark Side of
the Moon which was the first time I ever
tripped on but that's a complete
different [__] story all right
when I came back from down the shore I
was all in on Black Sabbath the first
time and I was all in unparanoid so I
said what's my next logical move I don't
know
I didn't even know there was no internet
it was Nike you couldn't Wikipedia what
the name of their albums were in
alphabetical order or whatever how they
came out and I didn't feel like [__]
asking people because people would my
time would go what the [__] are you
talking about don't you have all their
albums where are you a [__] what are
you listening to [__] Abba and I'm
like you know okay so I had to figure it
out on my own and I didn't know who to
ask and one day I went to that same
[__] album place
and I what [__] sabotage
and I brought that [__] home and
it just opened me the [__] up Ozzy was
tremendous the lyrics were great they
have an acoustic part on [__] symptom
of the universe and I I just it's just a
great owl megalomania the thrill of it
all the Writ the Writ is [__] scary
as [__] am I going insane and I was all
in [__] I was like wow this is
[__] deep and then I went back and I
bought Never say die again I went out of
order again and I bought the last album
and when I [__] Listen to Never Say
Die I was all in like that's my new
slogan Never say die I was [__] 14 15
I was very uh I was looking I didn't
have a father figure so I was looking
you know what I'm saying I'm not saying
Ozzy was my father figure but I'm just
saying that this album just blew me the
[__] apart and then something happened
I I got in to Never Say Die Junior's
eyes you know Johnny Blade [__] that
album has a lot of good songs on it
but at the same time I was putting on
different things every [__] day
and then the the next album I bought was
the one that put me over the [__] top
Sabbath Bloody Sabbath that song
just took me from point A to [__]
point B some about Sabbath Bloody
Sabbath
it was describing what I was going
through at the time I I don't know it
was all going on inside of me I was I
didn't want to live at home you know who
the [__] knows
but I don't know it got to me this out
and then my mother died
and when my mother died the albums I had
on the that I was listening to all the
time was the last Led Zeppelin
and uh the cars Candy-O that was the
little rotation I had at that time
and Sabbath Bloody Sabbath
and then when my mother died when I went
home I didn't want to put that [__]
double music on I was like I'm gonna
stay away from this devil music on I
moved in with the benders
and about two months later I started
listening to the Sabbath again
and I was [__] up by that so now it
just gripped me guys it gripped me in a
way that
it was all I was living for it was black
Black Sabbath was basically keeping me
the [__] alive as stupid as this [__]
sounds
as stupid as this sounds
and one day I was walking with Louis
castellito a couple of us it was cold
out it was
it was about
the end of January and I walked into a
magazine place
and Cream Magazine was that cream was
like you know Rolling Stones and
answered to heavy metal
and the [__] next thing you know I
open up the thing and it's official
Black Sabbath broke up
and I'm like [__] I really wanted them
to see him again because I had seen him
but I wasn't prepared
and I really liked him you know I really
liked what they were doing
and they broke up and the guys I was
like heartbroken like a [__] child
like a [__] child that was really
[__] heartbroken and I went that year
before my birthday I went
and I went up to this Barn 22nd and New
York Avenue used to be across from the
county Morgue there it's a funeral Paul
that's where they take you when you died
and that dispersion of either veneeries
or macagna or whatever there used to be
a bar there we used to get THC crystal
in that [__] AKA angel dust on
Tuesday nights they had an angel dust
happy hour I will never [__] forget
that and I went down there with a bunch
of savages and we bought like two two
tens of tea of uh
angel dust which we call Crystal and
I'll never forget I did two lines I
wasn't even living at home I was living
with the Benders and they weren't home
and I remember going in
putting
Master reality on that's the name of the
album the third album
putting it on and for some reason I was
going through the channels and The
Exorcist was on
meanwhile I'm tripping on [__] angel
dust
and I'm looking at [__] The Exorcist
and I'm hearing Black Sabbath in the
back have you ever thought about your
soul can it be saved you know the pope
dead on a rope and all this [__] and I'm
like [__] this out
the only thing I like to offer three was
Sweet Leaf I was like I ain't listening
to this [__] devil man I like
tomorrow's dream I think is on three but
no tomorrow's dream is on volume four I
said [__] this [__] I ain't putting this
[__] back on this is too dark for me
I'll keep it going with Sabbath Bloody
Sabbath at the time I was going through
a war with my father now with my
stepfather so now Sabbath Bloody Sabbath
was my Anthem every [__] morning I
was gonna kill this [__] I didn't
know how I was trying to rob him I was
trying to do everything I can to knock
him off his game
but I was [__] wounded I was walking
[__] wounded and uh
you know that's I guys I don't know I'm
mentally weak at that time
I was regressing you know after when you
were a young child and you see some type
of trauma you know you regress or stay
at that age until you come to terms with
that trauma
so I [__] I you know and I learned
this now and now it makes it a lot
easier for for me to understand what was
going on when I was 15 and my mother
died 16.
and I tell you guys
[__] Ozzy I don't know what the [__]
to say you know but I'm listening to
Aerosmith I'm listening to all this [__]
plus Pink Floyd The Wall had taken over
when Pink Floyd The Wall came out on
November 28th of 1979 that [__] came out
like a bullet and it cemented himself
you couldn't I remember going to Paramus
mall and listening to Pink Floyd The
Wall at every store please teacher leave
those kids alone and it was on the radio
which was never done before with Pink
Floyd except for money and that one
[__] Jam
so I'm like wow okay and [__]
John Lennon dies
challenge dies I think I hit the acid
one night Monday Night Football or he
dies Tuesday the city shuts down
they say that on Sunday they're gonna
have a uh
uh a memorial for John Lennon and
Strawberry Fields they're gonna do all
this [__] they're gonna lock down New
York and I just happen to go and I go I
don't want to go into Central Park if
it's going to be jammed [__] it I'll go
down to the village and see what's
happening in those days The Village was
a little Freer you know
and I remember going down there and
seeing the store Bleak of [__] Bob
said just going in there to buy like a
Blue Oyster Cult out I wanted to buy
like a Blue Oyster Cult out I'll never
forget this
the live one they have a live album
that's really [__] good Godzilla
don't feel the Reaper
it was like I don't know
that that's not on there no that was not
that that came out after they got
popular from that because they went on
tour
with Black Sabbath with Ronnie James Dio
and it was called the black and blue
tour
a lot of people don't remember this [__]
Monday more than [__] we're
dropping knowledge here
before we drop any more knowledge
I'm gonna cut over to an ad for better
help dig it what's up I want to talk to
you about better help when you feel
empowered you're more prepared to take
on everything life grows at you therapy
can get you to that place how do I know
because when I got off the plane here I
was a Momo in Jersey I didn't know what
was going on I was confused and I
somebody referred therapy to me and they
referred better help
and I signed up and Dana's helped me
tremendously better help is therapy
option that is convenient flexible
affordable and entirely online you fill
out a brief questionnaire you get
matched with a licensed therapist and
you switch therapists anytime for no
additional cost okay it couldn't be that
much easier so do me a favor if you're
stuck on something if you feel that
you're not there at this point in your
life
contact betterhelp.com
if you want to live more empowered life
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com enter code Diaz Diaz and
get 10 off your first month you'll have
somebody to talk to within 48 hours I
promise you you fill the questionnaire
out be honest they'll match you with the
therapist and you'll be fine and Tip Top
Magoo I was with them for a while and uh
I was talking to Dana every two weeks
and it really really helped so that's
betterhelp.com Diaz better help a
h-e-l-p.com slash Diaz and now back to
the podcast all right we're back I hope
you contact better help if you're having
some uh confusion in your life you don't
know what's going on they'll always help
you out anyway back to Ozzy Osbourne
here so
I uh go into the [__] Village
and I'm looking through album covers
and I don't know what the [__] I'm
buying I'm looking for blue eyes to coat
and right [__] there
said Ozzy
and they go ah because blue is right
next to Black you know before so they
had black and then they had Blue Oyster
Cult and then as I was walking down it
had Ozzy just playing Ozzy
and what the [__] is this and I pull out
a four song EP
and I'm looking at and it's Ozzy
Osbourne on the cover with the [__]
jacket on with the wings coming over
[__] Rudy Sawzall on the side not
really at the time it was the different
bass player
and then it was Randy on the side and
the old man drummer was on the back he
was like a hundred that dude he's still
around
and I remember looking at it and guys
I was there for John Lennon and Blue
Oyster Cult and I just bumped into my
[__] treasure
every feeling in my body just dumped out
it was just four songs Mr Crowley
I don't know
Suicide Solution
and something else that that was the
first four song EP from [__] uh [__]
nuts
so
so it sent me over guys I was so [__]
ecstatic and then a couple weeks later
the album came out
and I was [__] going off
but if Ozzy hadn't connected with me
before he had connected with me on this
album with the blizzard
guy and again I feel [__] like a
weakling telling you this story but it's
the truth
I didn't have anything else this was all
that was keeping me together
on that album he put out two songs that
really [__] stuck with me one is
Mother Revelation Mother Earth I just
lost my mother and this guy's talking
about a mother not only that Pink
Floyd's got a song on the wall about
mother
so it was a tough year for Uncle Joy
with mothers right everybody's coming
out with your mother mother and I'm
missing my mother but Ozzy's mother in
Revelation hit home but the song that
[__] destroyed me on that is I don't
know to have a verse and I don't know
that whenever I'm a little depressed I
still [__] sing it in my heart and
it's nobody ever told me I found out for
myself
you gotta believe in foolish Miracles
it's not how you play the game it's if
you win or lose you can't choose that
those words right there don't confuse
win or lose it's up to you
that has carried me for [__] 40
[__] years
those words are so [__] powerful in
that song that
and you know hearing Randy I'm the
guitar when Ozzy came back with that
band
it was the most exciting [__] thing
that happened since Leonard's gonna die
and then Bon Scott died
so the the community was a little low
when Ozzy came back out with that album
guys
you know I wish you could have
remembered it it just it took everything
down it was Game Over Van Halen was done
Van Halen came out with Van Halen too
everybody had a step aside for that
first [__] Aussie album everybody and
it was growing I mean it was in every
magazine now they were everywhere
Rolling Stone cream they were [__]
taking over
and I read about what happened you know
like and I want to know what happened
again there's no [__] internet guys
today you go on there and find anything
you want them back then when I was a kid
there was no [__] internet
but from Reading you know I read that
they threw them out of the band
you know for his drug use which I'm like
[__] I can't wait to get older so when
I'm in a band I get thrown out the drug
you see I'm saying like I just related
to this [__] mooc you know
and guys I saw him with uh Sabbath and
then tickets went on sale for [__]
the Palladium
with Randy Rhodes Rudy Sawzall
the drummer and [__] Ozzy Osbourne
and
I think 40 of us went
we would maybe sophomores in high school
juniors
40 of us [__] went and another
40 [__] from North Bergen were
there the older guys and he came out and
destroyed that [__] room
I still he opened up with um
and the place just [__] just erupted
guys and they did two shows yeah I don't
know he [__] came out with and the
best thing was at that time he still
wasn't [__] with Sabbath like he was
not doing any [__] Sabbath at all he
was just doing straight up [__] that
album you know it was tremendous the
night I saw him you know I don't
remember if he did Sabbath I could be
wrong there was a lot of drugs that
night he understand me we were in the
acidic state of mind but he was also
pushing the blizzard of Oz
now Ozzy had threatened like in 75 to
leave Sabbath or maybe he did leave
seven and he started a band called The
Blizzard of Oz that was short-lived for
years I saw those pictures with him with
blizzard the blizzard guys
that was my again
I'm not going to be like one of these
guys that sues the cigarette company
after they smoked all their life and
they get cancer
if I had any doubts about not doing coke
Ozzy erased that [__] like he was he was
my [__] I still remember being in a
cemetery with my friend Carlos
and laying getting son in a cemetery and
snorting bumps just because of lying
snow blind in the sun soon my Ice Age
yet to come I mean guys I'm a [__]
geek okay I'm a drug geek and he just
lit that [__] match for me you know
it was like the first time you listened
to
[__] Girl by Hall and Oates Rich Girl
when you're when you're in the sixth
grade and that song came on you lost
your mind you know why because you said
the word [__]
you're a child he said [__] you know I
remember when Chuck Barry came out with
my ding-a-ling
and we were like in the fifth grade we
everybody bought My Ding-A-Ling asked me
what my dingling is today I don't even
want to see that [__] album it's a
horrible album but you're young and
you're you're uh very you know
you fall for that [__] and I fell for it
like I loved but there was a lot of [__]
about Ozzy that I liked early on that a
lot of people didn't know I liked I
wasn't just a fan of his because of
drugs he can't he's not a great singer
doesn't happen it doesn't have a lot of
doesn't have a lot of range you know if
you watch Ozzy there was just something
about him you know there's some people
who are tremendous [__] singers and
they got a whole career going [__]
rob Alford that [__] could sing
since day one not for everybody's taste
but he could sing you know Pat metatar
could sing not just rock that [__] used
to be an opera singer she could [__]
sing Ozzy was always like you know you
rate Ozzy as a singer he's a [__] six
but his [__] story
his [__] story
is beautiful
you know that neighborhood Birmingham
England that ain't no [__] there
ain't no Beverly Hills
that is not Beverly Hills and them and
Judas priests came out of Birmingham
England
you know and they [__] all those
[__] bands that's Savages those
people are savages they eat toenails you
saw what he was doing he was [__]
licking piss off the floor Ozzy was a
[__] Savage not for a while yes you
know it went somewhere else he what he
bit the hat off the pigeon that's not my
world that's not my world I invite no
[__] head off no pigeon but
you know he when the story god listen
sabotage is such a great album because
they were Furious
The Story Goes that they were just
getting ripped off by the music label
you know did you just say this week or
two weeks ago John Fogerty just got the
rights back to his music that's [__]
huge that's huge that they were at War
it doesn't really matter what I'm trying
to say is that the 70s and 60s
in rock music it was a [__]
free-for-all it was a steel Fest
Led Zeppelin was making boxes of [__]
money
and they dictated the market how they
didn't get charged with tax fraud and
all that [__] in the 70s I read the
books I got 10 Led Zeppelin books Bobby
Lingus has sent me they were making
boxes of money God knows what Peter
Grant was [__] stealing you know and
uh Sharon Sharon Osbourne's father was
the original manager to Black Sabbath he
had that label in England or whatever
and he was robbing them blind they had
no [__] money and sabotage they were
on the road for like three years they
had no money
no money gangstered no money like not
like well we'll send you a report no I
didn't know money
like we gave you 28 balls
like that's what they were doing to
these guys it was [__] rough and when
you do like as a civilian at that time I
didn't feel the pain but once I became a
comic I'm like [__] I know exactly what
that feels like there's people will run
these contracts and they tell you
they're going to pay you this amount and
then you don't get another dime
throughout the rest of the [__] they
keep it off but meanwhile they're
telling you all yeah you'll get a check
once a [__] month they robbed those
guys
when Sharon found Ozzy
this [__] was living on top of
the liquor store on Sunset Boulevard
in a one-bedroom apartment they wanted
to get rid of them they're like he's
he's done
they wrote him the [__] off guys
when I found these stories out like in
82 83 when I started more [__] started
coming out I was blowing the [__] away
he was one of the top singers in the top
band nine [__] albums and this guy
was broke living on top of that's I
forget the liquor store name like it's a
bit herbs or something it's a popular
liquor store this [__] was
living up there with ugots
nothing
she's the one that [__] got him up
and said uh you know get up that's why
when you see her I give her all the
credit in the [__] world she [__]
brought a dead man back to life
she really [__] did you see what he
did he just didn't come back with a
great album he came back with two or
three great [__] albums and then the
guy died then he replaced him then he
started [__] he put a festival
together
he put a badass [__] Festival
together this guy took the ball and ran
guys
then they started reality TV I mean guys
he was at the Forefront and it was all
her
you know and in a way you look at them
and you're like you know he's just a
[__] mooger you know they just pull
him by a [__] string keep giving them
[__] pills he's one of those guys
that for years they argue is he sober is
he not sober dark
let me tell you something guys like that
those geezers from the 70. they'll never
be sober I deal with an uncle right now
the guy that was my best man this
[__] always got something wrong
and he'll tell you I'm sober because for
them they're sober
for them they're [__] sober
so for everybody else you're like you're
still eating pills nah I'm sober
compared to what I was doing six eight
balls a bottle of vodka a bottle of
tranquilizes [__] Gorilla Biscuits
I'm sober and I get that with him but
I've always respected the [__] out of
him and this week and it was weird
because one of my guys on patreon hit me
up and he's like describe the Black
Sabbath concert for me the first one you
went then I'm like this is the weirdest
thing in the world the next day was when
Ozzy came out and goes I saw the video
when I looked at the [__] video it
broke my heart
he gave it it's all nobody ever thought
that dude would still be alive nobody
including me I was like that
motherfucker's gonna die from all the
cocaine use and [__]
that cocaine use made him and Keith
Richards tougher than [__] and just the
fact that these guys this is why
somebody told me this a couple years ago
I think it was Rudy Sawzall who said
the Legends are going back on the road
this is your time to go see them
this is your time to go see them if you
ever had a really really want to go see
somebody for the last time whatever
because you don't want to [__] I know
I want to see Ozzy again I didn't know
how I was going to see him but he might
do like a residency that's what they're
pushing for he's not going to quit live
performing he could still sin he just
doesn't want to [__] travel hello
would you want to [__] travel you
know what I'm saying so uh it's going to
be interesting where this goes but just
the summer's coming I know a lot I know
next week right down right down the
corner it's Motley Crue at the Hard Rock
where we went to see Rogan there oh it's
Motley Crue with Def Leppard
you know these guys aren't going away
and you know you sit there and you go do
I really want to pay 200 bucks to see
Def Leppard
I didn't
two weeks ago
but now
I think I'm gonna go see these guys one
last time I grew up on this [__]
music guys
you know concerts have changed a lot you
know I see these post Malone shows and
[__] like that [__] that I would never
go to those things you know but I still
want to see some old [__] rockers I
really wanted to see Aerosmith in Vegas
I think that's a tremendous residency
anybody who's gone to see it it says
it's [__] tremendous
uh he might be done
you know he might be done Stephen Tyler
guys it's [__] tough
I asked uh I noticed testosterone doctor
in L.A and I asked him you know who he
who his number one patients were
and he was I thought it was
was it actors
or football players he told me that it
was musicians
we then get into particulars but but
when I went to his wedding the guy from
Bush was there with she was still
married to Gwen Stefani so when I went
to this doctor's wedding I saw them then
a couple other people I didn't really
know who they were they all had fancy
hair and blue hair and [__] but I know
he had a couple bands so I asked him why
do the musicians shoot I'm not saying
Aussie shot I'm just telling you what is
the protocol right now
first off these older bands they only do
three shows a week
that's all they can handle and they take
a night off in between and I don't know
if you guys ever saw the Alex Rodriguez
testosterone thing Alex Rodriguez would
take a gummy in the sixth inning a
testosterone gummy they made a
testosterone gummy fan so he would come
alive
in the 7th 8th and ninth inning
so and then when he got on stage it was
such a light boost that it wouldn't
appear in his urine or something they
did do something that's what he was
telling me they're doing with the rock
stars
they do the testosterone a little bit
before the show or that morning and then
uh like 30 minutes into the show they
give the drummer a solo and they all go
back there they take a [__] shot and
they go out to the and that's what the
dog I can't send 70. my friends went to
see [__] Jeff Beck and they said Jeff
Beck was older than [__] God Rest his
soul I'm not here to insult nobody but
they say he couldn't even move he just
stood up that plane you know uh look
what happened with my man Mick Mars he's
done you know and I [__] love that
[__] that [__] could
shred he looks like a [__] old Giza
but he could [__] he could shred bro
that dude could [__] shred but that's
it it's the end and if you look at
what's coming up what do we got left
what do we got left
we got David Grohl we got those guys
I mean big bands you mean right
yes
I mean uh I can't I could see guns still
being out there but they got to put out
new music eventually
they have to support their next door
with something or something somebody's
gonna light themselves on fire
something I mean I really appreciate
that I love [__] Guns and Roses but
they're starting to get you know every
day you go in your car and there's
Paradise City
I'm waiting and I I have tried putting
on like uh use your illusion like on
YouTube when I'm writing or something
Reading yeah go through the whole thing
you know Pearl Jam still throwing Heat
I always take a figure out a way to get
sound garden back but nobody wants to
see God in the sun without Chris Cornell
that's that's just a stupid idea Joey uh
Allison Chains is still throwing heat
I'm going to see with you we're going to
see Rudy May 2nd at njpac
got like eight tickets for us he said to
give you two of them
you know now I feel bad I feel bad about
the attitude I had
the last 10 years living in L.A you know
I tried to go see Michael shankner every
[__] year and I always had a stupid
[__] date when he came to town
you know uh you know and I just I put
I put comedy and I let uh stand up get
in the way of my music career for a long
[__] time
you know I'm a big music guy music is
music lifts my spirits
it's times I'm down
I could smoke a half a number and put an
album on and then I'm Brandon the [__]
no I mean it's music just uh it really
affects who the [__] I am you know I
like coming back every once in a while
sometimes I don't even play the music I
just look through the albums and it
gives me the strength of 10 dead
Iranians I just [__] you know I'll
I'll read the wall of [__]
it's Monday [__] what do you
want we got a big [__] week this week
man if you really think about it you got
a big Sports week I know a lot of you
[__] are getting ready for the
Super Bowl what are you gonna wear what
are you gonna eat
I'm gonna eat some mushrooms I just gave
Mike a little five man package let me
see that [__] bag right here
these things are tremendous sillies are
[__] taking over they also have
chocolate now now I've gotten some
chocolate mushrooms in town here
they taste like dick okay
dog you gotta taste Silly's chocolate
they taste so [__] good the
chocolate's like water really
Guadalajara what's that [__]
chocolate giordelli it's like that guys
that's how good the chocolate is and
it's shiny it's dark chocolate cacao
which is good for you you know they even
for my age they said you should eat some
cacao dark cocoa whatever the [__] it is
once or twice a week the dark don't eat
regular chocolate
eat dark chocolate so yeah I'm gonna eat
some [__] I got some shrooms saved for
the soup bowl
it's a big night Saturday night you got
my man [__] bolonovski you got
mickelshoff whatever you know I'm not
going with Russian names whatever the
[__] I I don't know what the hell's
going on anymore uh you got [__]
Super Bowl the over the under you got so
many games going on and listen guys I
love working for DraftKings I love
[__] DraftKings but let's get
something straight
I am not here telling you to [__]
place a bet or whatever I'm telling you
read my words I'm telling you to have
fun
everything has an entertainment value
it's the value you put on it okay if you
want to spend 800 for Roger Waters go
ahead some people look at me and they go
I'll give 200 for that communist after
that I don't want this I ain't paying a
dime over that [__] you know
it's the same thing with
having a good time
if you want to have a good time what do
you want to do you want to have stakes
and people jumping up and down and
[__] flying through the air you got
to go for the 150 steak you know what
I'm saying it's the same thing so for me
Thug I get when I was a kid and I used
to gamble because that's what you do
when you're an idiot you gamble and you
lose that's one thing but when you
play you know what the things are and
you know this is just this is just a
game
25 isn't gonna affect my family if I bet
a game for 25 bucks if I bet a game for
100 bucks it will affect my family these
are things you got to know on your own
you know
last two nights ago there was a UFC I
didn't nothing me now I'm into college
basketball if I see something I like
Ohio State or something 25 bucks It's
Entertainment sometimes I even check to
see what's on TV at night and if there's
a game coming on I'll just try my
[__] basketball knowledge for 25
bucks you know uh I love them as a
company they got great customer service
and I've been with them for three years
I think I've been with them before I was
a uh I was with them a year before I
even started working with them like I
enjoyed them I tried a couple different
companies but I really like [__]
DraftKings and that's why I ended up
partnering up with them so uh they're
gonna have some great things going on
for the Super Bowl don't forget if
you're in Jersey [__] uh Stoner Club
you want to be prepared I'm gonna try to
get them some [__] uh laughing gas by
the soup bowl I promise you
[__] but tomorrow's anything go
Monday today is anything go Monday you
get like 10 off all your orders give
them a stoner club.com and uh use Uncle
Joey and that's it [__] it's a
great Monday I'm great I'm happy to be
alive I'm happy for you [__] my
patreon is at the best point I've ever
had them they're all normal
for years I had all these crazy people
talking about the weather and [__] nah I
got people with real problems that and
we communicate it's [__] great on
that uh and that's it guys I'm just
having a good time and uh slinging dick
and giving out Chopsticks that's what we
do around here my uncle Joey's joint so
stay black have a great week and here's
a word from our sponsors [__] see
you next Monday morning after the Super
Bowl all right you bad [__]
thank you for letting me talk about Ozzy
today I just thought that uh it's What
drew me off the boat last week but I'm
back [__] thank you for supporting me
before I gotta get out of here listen
this episode was sponsored by better
help when you feel empowered you're more
prepared to take on everything life
throws at you I was a better help for at
least a year and they took me out of my
funk and put me in the right place Dana
did a great job better help is the
therapy option that it's really
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online you don't have to leave
your house just fill out a brief
questionnaire get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime with no additional charge it
couldn't be any easier right if you want
to live a more empowered life and have
control of your life let betterhelp.com
Diaz get you there and when you sign up
today I'm going to get you 10 off your
first month all right that's
betterhelp.com
Diaz the joint is also brought to you by
rocket money formerly known as true bill
you're paying too much via subscriptions
you don't even know what the hell you
got out there cable bills this that
masseuses that's why I love rocket money
formerly known as true bill the app
shows you all your subscriptions in one
place and cancels whatever ones you
don't want it's that easy they can even
find the ones you didn't even know you
had so you may even find out you're
being double charged how's that for you
download rocket money today right now
just press cancel and Rocket money takes
care of the rest get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocket money right
now go to rocketmoney.com Joey seriously
I'm Gonna Save You hundreds per year and
you're gonna really love me then you
little dirty animals that's
rocketmoney.com
Joey cancel your unnecessary
subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com
Joey and the joint is also brought to
you by listen either you're gonna get
the party started this weekend or you're
not we're talking about two fights and
then a tremendous football game in fact
the biggest one of the year on Sunday
and you're sitting here looking around
like what am I doing this weekend listen
I got it all planned out for you you're
gonna download the draftkingsports book
app right now they're an official sports
betting part in the UFC you can't go
wrong new customers you bet five dollars
I'm Gonna Get You 200 and bonus bets
right there just for the signing up
that's how Uncle Joey does it and if the
excitement of the Octagon isn't enough
if seeing some guys eyeball fly out of
his head ain't good for you get the big
game happening on Sunday at DraftKings
Sportsbook and DraftKings fantasy app
download the app now use code Joey new
customers better Finn to get in five
dollars on UFC 284 and get 200 bonus
bets instantly this Saturday DraftKings
sports book called Joey j-o-e-y minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes for details I want to
thank rocket money I want to thank
DraftKings and I want to thank better
help for always having my back but I
want to thank you [__] stay
black have a great week Uncle Joey loves
you
foreign